hello I'm in Frank's and I can't quite
believe where I am tonight I'm here in
London for what is the biggest most
anticipated blockbuster in the Himax
counter is finally here people wrote one
a style story they are requesting a call
sign its own rogue rogue one
[Music]
rogue one is the first stand-alone Star
Wars movie in the time of conflict a
group of unlikely heroes led by felicity
jones band together on a mission to
steal plans to the desktop
Oh mr. rogue one is very much in the
opening of the new hope that's how the
film is described in the opening call so
it's pretty much sets up you know
there's wonderful opening scenes over
Slayer how she got there and how that
came about so in a way you don't need to
have seen any of the other films times
doubt going on in this to really enjoy
it but it can definitely also be seen
when you see all the others because then
you will see how it's linked to new hope
and linked to the other films actually
that comes before it characters make
such an exciting and different kind of
Star Wars movie it really keeps you on
the edge of your seat and we were all
blown when we first saw it all put
together we've stunned into silence
which for a bunch of actors is rare Oh
rebellion it's all that remains to push
back the Empire is the darkest times in
the galaxy you know there's no Jedi
surround this film is about the people
taking control and throwing that team
work makes it very strong and it's
entertaining and at the same time as a
very deep and positive message behind it
it's really rare to be able to be part
of a film that you know so many people
are going to go and see if ever there
was a saga destined for the imax
experience it Star Wars I rode one
director Gareth Edwards tells us why
heat things movie lovers should go rogue
in imax imax has really built cinema and
if it's built for any kind of cinema is
built for epic cinema
and I don't think it gets more acting in
Star Wars like it defined epic when you
see in the home axis like there's some
massive massive screen experience also
the sound experience is very important
to kind of sweeps you up gives your
search doesn't get any better than this
the whole world has come undone oh it's
beautiful it's finally time and oh my
gods I are beyond excited I let's do
this properly make sure you got rogue in
imax
[Music]
you
[Music]
you